[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue sur figaro la
journée donc sur le site du figaro on
est en direct
on attend vos points de vue notamment
sur cette idée d'interdire les
rassemblements familiaux pour lutter
contre la propagation du coronavirus est
ce que vous êtes d'accord qu'est ce que
vous en pensez et bien vous nous le
dites en direct on va confronter vos
points de vue avec ceux d'alexandre ii
vecchio bonsoir alexandra journaliste au
service débat opinion du figaro est en
charge de figaro bugs auteurs
dernièrement d'un livre à lire
absolument ces recompositions le nouveau
monde populiste et c'est aux éditions du
cerf les livres de nicolas baverez sont
à lire absolument d'abord il yal alerte
démocratique mais il y a aussi le monde
selon tocqueville et dans les deux cas
c'est à lire absolument tout comme la
dernière chronique de nicolas baverez
rays qui était dans l'édition papier du
figaro de ce lundi b à retrouver
également sur figure au vox l'archipel
isation du monde je les écris en capital
parce que effectivement ça pour ça la
dyslexie ou comment les conflits qui se
multiplient qui menace la cohésion
international je vous propose d'y
revenir à travers la réponse qu'il faut
apporter aux menaces turque où c'est
plus exactement une question l'europe
doit-elle jouer un rôle de la robe
l'europe peut-elle jouer un rôle on vous
pose déjà la question sur twitter on y
revient en deuxième partie de débat
d'abord la question à laquelle il faut
répondre
elle est sur le site du figaro c'est
faut-il interdire les rassemblements
familiaux et les mariages pour lutter
contre la propagation du coronavirus
alors juste avant le début
de ce débat vous étiez très partagés sur
la question 50 50
il faut dire que la pression sur les
familles en tout cas on peut pas le nier
est maximale le préfet la préfète de
nouvelles aquitaine vient d'interdire
les soirées dansantes au sein des
mariages et s'est dernièrement hier dans
le journal du dimanche une demi douzaine
de médecins demander l'arrêt des
rassemblements familiaux
il y a également cet extrait d'un clip
diffusé par le ministère de la santé
[Musique]
elle décide
j'allais à 126 jeunes faire mon travail
on peut tous être touché alors on doit
tous se protéger ensemble continuons
d'appliquer les gestes barrière besoin
des 2 0 800 130 000 appels gratuits plus
d'informations sur gouvernement.fr ceci
est un message du ministère des
solidarités et de la sont alors les
couleurs je vous demander votre réaction
je voudrais d'abord vous faire écouter
celle d'un homme qui n'est pas réputé
pour être un grand pôle promoteur de la
politique familiale
c'était yannick jadot ce matin sur
france inter et on le conseil
scientifique et il sait dire lévis le
conseil scientifique s'exprime à travers
la voix de son président qui matin midi
et soir cherche surtout à [ __ ] la
trouille aux français je sais pas si ça
être toujours y compris quand on a un
tel bazar au niveau des tests on fout la
trouille aux français et on se plaint
que isaï se faire tester il ya des
magouilles la raison yannick jadot
il ya clairement raison en tout cas sur
ce sur ce point c'est à dire le on a un
vrai problème d'incohérence de la
position du gouvernement
entre ce qu'on a vu des messages qui
sont extrêmement anxiogènes un président
du conseiller de ce conseil scientifique
qui est complètement sorti de son rôle
certains conseils c'est un rôle d'avis à
donner au gouvernement et en aucun cas
ça un rôle d'expression publique à la
place des responsables gouvernementaux
donc si on veut avoir une transparence
qui est souhaitable en publions rend
publiques les avis ou les débats à
l'intérieur de ce conseil mais on n'a
certainement pas un président de cette
instance qui se promène entre
l'assemblée le sénat et les médias pour
annoncer soi disant des choses
extrêmement difficile compliqué et
derrière avoir un premier ministre qui
confine au ridicule en expliquant que la
mesure difficile c'est le passage de l'
isolement de 14 jours à 7 jours donc on
a un dégré d'incohérences à la tête
aujourd'hui de découvrir quoi selon vous
je pense qu'on court toujours après le
ratage du début sur les masques dont il
ya une perte de lui
timité des responsables publics et un
climat de défiance qui s'est instaurée
et depuis on n'arrive pas à retrouver
une ligne et on a par ailleurs une
organisation qui est vicié il faut quand
même dire les choses par leur nom
il est complètement absurde de gérer une
crise qui est d'abord une crise civile à
l'intérieur d'un conseil de défense qui
est d'abord une instance militaire
depuis le début on a vu cette confusion
complète avec une communication démesuré
autour d'un hôpital de campagne à
mulhouse alors que c'était pas du tout
le problème
donc il faudrait qu'on revienne
absolument à de la cohérence entre le
côté sanitaire le côté économique et
surtout qu'on se rappelle que c'est là
où le président macron s'est trompée
depuis le début en faisant sa première
intervention sur le thème de la guerre
c'est pas une guerre mais dame merkel
elle l'a compris maintenant le conseil
de madame merkel d'abord les gens se
taisent et ensuite qui on trouve on
trouve des représentants des länder
des représentants des grandes
entreprises parce que c'est eux qui ont
su acheter des masques parce qu'ils sont
en chine on trouve si vous voulez le le
ce qu'il faut pour une gérer une crise
civile et sanitaire complexe c'est à
dire de l'état et des représentants de
la société de l'état central et de
l'état local et un conseil de défense
c'est pas du tout faits pour ça
donc depuis le début on a un système de
gestion de cette crise qui est aberrant
et malheureusement on en paye le prix
avant de donner la réponse à la question
la question la réponse la parole
alexandre et savoir de vous adonner
salue d'ailleurs pierre pierre
abdelkader qui nous rejoint karima qui
nous rejoignent également sur youtube où
jean loup on va vous donner la parole
justement c b le cas d'ailleurs qui nous
demande on peut pas empêcher les gens de
dents au sein des familles qu'est ce que
vous pensez justement de cette de ce
qu'on entend là ses dernières heures on
quand on dans ce clip qu'on a vu on me
soutenir dans ce clip il est scandaleux
il complètement oxygène d'ailleurs où on
a un précédent rappelez-vous avec la
sécurité routière
quand on a voulu diffuser des clips qui
était totalement oxygène et a poussé
vraiment un terrain non ça n'a pas
marché mais ça n'a pas marché non ça n'a
pas marché du tout parce que les le
malade est ce justement parce que les
choses sont tellement violentes que les
gens refusent complètement
d'entraînement et il a par ailleurs
c'est vrai que il ya cette espèce de
mise en accusation des familles ou des
qui est complètement déraisonnable si on
parle des personnes âgées par ailleurs
il faut quand même rappeler que ce qui
s'est passé dans les ehpad a été
scandaleux aussi parce que on a laissé
mourir de manière complètement indigne
un certain nombre de personnes qui ont
été complètement coupés de leur
entourage qui a beaucoup de personnes
âgées pour lesquelles le fait de ne plus
avoir aucun contact avec des gens qu'ils
qu'elle connaissait a fait autant
d'hommages de dommage que le que le coc
vide
et si vous voulez j'en reviens à une
chose qui est fondamental qu'elle est
quel est le problème de cette épidémie
le problème c'est la résilience il faut
qu'on lutte contre l'épidémie et qu'en
même temps on organise la continuité de
la vie nationale alors juste alors je
veux maintenant on va interdire les
mariages et on devra aller carrément à
l'essentiel il faut interdire les décès
comme ça au moins on n'en était pas loin
parce qu'on a interdit les légendes de
cérémonie religieuse pendant un long
moment ça aussi c'était vous parlez du
dam des ehpad le fait pour certaines
familles de ne pas pouvoir dire au
revoir à leur mort je pense que ça a été
quelque chose d'extrêmement
douloureux et d' extrêmement excessif de
la part de l'état mme j'évite les
réunions de famille nous dit karima mais
ils finissent tous chez moi le dimanche
leur expliquer qu'ici fiche de leur
bien-être et du miam fatigue
en revanche j'ai envie de vous demander
mais sans le sacrifice des familles on
risque pas un nouveau confinement qui
serait fatal pour l'économie je ne crois
pas que je n'y crois pas je crois que ce
qui est fatal pour l'économie
effectivement c'est de cette politique
de la peur très bien dénoncé par par
nier que la bave rays et qu'au contraire
pour rebâtir un pays on va avoir besoin
des familles d'ailleurs je ne pense pas
que ce soit forcément anticipé par le
gouvernement je pense que c'est
effectivement comme l'a dit nicolas
baverel une dérive du conseil
scientifique qui s'inscrit dans une
dérive à mon avis plus large c'est ça
les scientifiques a demandé un c'est
plutôt des médecins c'est les
collectivités les maires ça mais on est
on a effectivement le conseil
scientifique qui prend la parole sans
arrêt a donc on a une dérive de la
technocratie de l' expertise qui a
tendance à prendre le pas sur sur
l'exécutif mais peut-être aussi parce
qu'il a laissé la main et qui s'est
montré impuissant et incohérent
maintenant sur la l'idéologie globale
que cela traduit je trouve ça
intéressant parce que tout se passe
comme si on voulait aller vers une
société de plus en plus atomisé
on voit bien qu une des conséquences de
cette crise va être le plat prise de
pouvoir d'une certaine manière de la
confirmation de la prise de pouvoir de
l'économie virtuelle sur l'économie
réelle avec notamment le
l'affaiblissement des commerces de
proximité etc
l'avènement du télétravail avec les
effets positifs que ça peut avoir mais
aussi un certain nombre d'effets
négatifs en termes de de précarisation
de présence humaine le masque qui nous
éloignent quand même les uns des autres
et aujourd'hui la famille qui est quand
même le socle
un des socles de la société et donc si
on veut s'en aller vers une société
atomisée de l'individu postmodern dance
est très grande solitude
on ne s'y prendrait pas mieux donc je
commence aussi à m'inquiéter sur les
conséquences qui pourra y avoir quand on
vous fera vraiment sortir de cette crise
là je spatiaux que la domitienne
houellebecq dizaine à la société d'avant
en pierre je crois qu'on se dirige
vraiment vers ce gars là vers des
univers type des romans des romans de
houellebecq je vais y arriver
d'après lui les corps ou lé voilà
nicolas je reviens avec elles sont je
posais alexandre est ce que quand même
il faut pas passer par ce sacrifice au
sein des familles pour éviter un nouveau
confinement qui serait fatal pour
l'économie le but
là encore il faudrait complètement
renversé le raisonnement c'est à dire
que de même que le but c'est de lutter
contre l'école l'épidémie en faisant
marcher l'économie
si on veut libérer les 85 milliards d'
épargne des français
c'est certainement pas en leur donnant
qui n'ont plus le droit de se voir
qu'ils n'ont plus droit de sortir de
chez eux qu'ils n'ont plus le droit
d'aller dans des commerces et donc la
logique du effectivement cette logique
du repli sur soi elle est terrible il
est terrible aussi pour le pour la vie
sociale donc de même que ce qui les
conseillent qui devrait être donnée
c'est pas du tout ces espèces
d'interdiction dé sait comment est ce
que vous pouvez vous voir en par
ailleurs en ne prenant pas de risques
déraisonnables
c'est ça qui devrait être la logique du
gouvernement c'est celle-là logis ce que
j'appelle la logique de la résilience et
la logique de la continuité de la vie
nationale
c'est pas d'arrêter la vie familiale
d'arrêter la vie économique est
d'arriver on continue à être dans une
logique de 2
de confinement donc c'est ça dont il
faut sortir et se remettent dans une
logique positive c'est comment je fais
marcher cette économie ce pays cette
nation tout en luttant contre l'économie
je sais comment on fait on applique le
truc qui est quand même 2 on en revient
toujours à ça depuis le début dans tous
les pays qui ont réussi et qu'on ne fait
pas chez nous testé on sait que les
tests c'est il ya un espèce d'énormes
embouteillages il ya toujours pas de
tests rapides
on se demande ce que fait l'état ensuite
tracé il prend de prendre la tva sur les
masques dits gertrude et elle trouve
thomas coville est un et est un fiasco
épouvantable comment est ce qu'on peut
imaginer maintenant on dit comment vous
lâcher 2000 personnes pour faire des
mais on est au 19ème temps on conteste
au lieu d'avoir ces espèces de wilex que
j'appelais les brigades du pangolin
évidemment qu'il faut faire ça avec des
outils numériques est donc dans mais ça
n'a pas marché avec stop ça peut pas
marcher puisque ont fait contre les
fabricants de portables donc ça il
fallait l'inventer quand même l'avenir
il faudra avoir les tests c'est aussi sa
chanson il faut isoler et on isole
toujours pas et enfin il faut soigner et
donc il faut avoir des capacités qui
monte en gamme par exemple c'est parfois
pardon faut se réunit avec cours mais il
faut soigner avec des lits de
réanimation et de la ventilation
puis sous équipés et vous voyez en
guadeloupe au jeu il ya 28 lits de
réanimation en a 20 qui sont déjà
occupés donc effectivement on peut se
demander comment depuis le mois de mars
qu'on n'a pas eu l'idée de se dire que
dans un département comme la guadeloupe
il faudrait avoir une capacité soit
supérieur marinina confiné mais on n'a
pas confiné temps pas par la létalité de
la maladie est d'ailleurs la maladie est
aujourd'hui moins virulente que parce
qu'on n'avait pas les capacités
d'accueil et de soins qu'il faut tout
mettre en oeuvre pour qu'on ait les
capacités d'accueil et de soin et une
ventilation enfin session c'est ces
tests oui exactement
et j'ajoute une chose dans les pas de
riez raout
il faut faire parler de roxy chloroquine
mai
puis pourquoi pas pour les docks tive
chloroquine ça c'était s'aimer mais
c'est en plus mais déjà concédé qu'on
est toutes les capacités d'accueil
nécessaires et enfin juste un mot qui se
situe dans ce que je disais tout à
l'heure oui un monde où elle détient et
puis un monde de l'interdiction
permanente de tous alors jadot la
véraison dans cet extrait l'âme et de
les verts veulent interdire le sapin
c'est qu'un autre sus est un autre sujet
c'est un autre sujet mais on a quand
même un sujet parce qu'on avait faits
relate l'agression qu'on fait tout pour
emmerder les français voudraient on veut
qu'ils aient d'activité de la croissance
ce n'est peut-être pas le le moment avec
centre vous pouvez pas dire là c'est pas
les écolos qui en tout cas c'était pas
yannick jadot qui non mais non c'est ça
et même été sévère envers ses propres
tour tan dung il faut lui reconnaître
pour mr des français il n'y a pas de
monopole d'aucun camp et jean-pierre
nous fier que je salue qui a tout de
suite pris la parole sur le chat du
figaro nous dit avec des masques on peut
tout faire mariages fêtes de famille
match de foot spectacle tout olympe que
je sais lui fidèle fidèles internautes
du figaro nous donne son age moi j'ai 74
ans et je ne suis pas choqué par le clip
les gens ne veulent juste pas comprendre
pierre alors nous croient que c'est
pierre n'est pas convaincu par votre
stratégie nicolas il dit elle est
mauvaise parce qu'elle ne vise pas la
suppression du virus du coup l'économie
ne peut pas se rétablir et toute façon
la suppression du virus si je puis dire
on peut l'obtenir que par deux choses
qui n'existent pas aujourd'hui c'est à
dire soit un vaccin soit un traitement
et donc à l'immunité d'euros mais le
groupe voilà il faut accepter quand même
entre temps des pertes humaines qui
seront considérables donc tant qu'on n'a
pas ni vaccin ni traitement de toute
manière il ne reste plus que ce qui a
marché
partout dans les pays qui ont réussi
c'est à dire la corée taïwan la nouvelle
zélande
l'allemagne ou les pays scandinaves
cette stratégie elle est bien connu
d'ailleurs à lire aujourd'hui validée
par par l' oms donc si ensuite on veut
supprimer c'est vrai que toute façon il
ya deux solutions vaccin traitement pour
l'instant ça n'existe pas qu'est ce que
vous répondez à la qui dit que vous avez
une stratégie strictement économique
tandis que le problème et médicales mais
je pense que opposait les deux n'a aucun
sens pourquoi parce qu'on peut pas faire
repartir l'économie
si on n'a pas une stratégie sanitaire
qui fonctionne et al'inverse faire une
stratégie de confinement généralisée
pour tuer l'économie ça veut dire que de
toute manière on aura plus de morts par
l'effondrement de l'économie de la
société que par l'épidémie donc cette
espèce d'opposition elle est
complètement fausse que j'explique c'est
qu'il faut précisément arriver à une
stratégie globale qui fasse marcher les
2es et ça n'est que par une stratégie
claire de lutte contre cette épidémie
qu'on peut avoir une relance vrai parce
que ça permet de rétablir la confiance
et d'enlever la peur et de même ça n'est
qu'avec une économie qui fonctionne
qu'on peut limiter les dommages de plus
je suis pas soupçonnable d'être
économiste mais effectivement je rejoins
ce raisonnement et puis je veux bien
qu'on place la vie où tu touches fasse
apparaître le bon sens mais il faut
aussi se demander l'avis pour quoi faire
si on finit tous sous cloche je pense
pas que cette vie et beaucoup de sens là
je pense que c'est important notamment
pour les personnes âgées qui continuent
à avoir leurs petits enfants qui
continuent à voir leur famille sinon ils
vont perdre toute saveur à la vie et ce
sera peut-être plus finalement on
dangereux pour eux que le virus lui même
faut-il interdire les mariages les
rassemblements familiaux c'est la
question qu'on pose sur le site du
figaro je suis de vous dire messieurs en
tout cas qu'elle n'avait pas encore
convaincu tous les internautes du figaro
qui sont
en ce moment assez nombreux dans le site
et à suivre est également à voter
puisque pour l'instant il 51% une légère
majorité donc est favorable à
l'interdiction je regarde encore de
nouveau sur le site ci sachant si ça a
changé et c'est dans 51 1% contre 4 48
8% donc
et bien pour l'instant vous pouvez
continuer à voter
et cette question est en ligne jusqu'à
demain il ya une autre question qu'on
vous pose cette fois-ci aller sur
twitter c'est ce que peut faire l'europe
contre les menaces turc apparemment les
amis d erdogan se sont mobilisés sur
youtube si je suis les commentaires
avant même que le débat soit lancé
en tous les cas le navire turc horus
raïs qui était un navire d'exploration
sismique est rentré au port 24 heures
après l'annnonce de la commande de
rafale pour la grèce pour contrer les
mener turc au large des côtes grecs et
en méditerranée orientale
la france est en première ligne avec le
déploiement notamment de plusieurs
bâtiments le tonnerre la frégate la
fayette des voix en appellent à l'europe
alors que l'otan l'alliance atlantique
ou encore les états unis sont aux
abonnés absents dans cette dans cette
affaire vous même nicolas baverez vous
écrivez dans le figaro donc ce matin
l'europe peut devenir un laboratoire de
conciliation entre souveraineté
nationale et intégration continentale
résilience et ouverture sécurité et
liberté
alors avant d'avoir justement votre
plaidoyer sur 7 sur 7 sur cette
affirmation je demande justement ça son
commentaire et sa réaction à alexandre
sûr sûr sûr sûr ce point alors
indépendamment de ce qu'il faut faire
face arrière dos d'âne
effectivement ce serait merveilleux si
on se mettait tous d'accord pour pour le
sanctionner lui faire face et établir un
véritable rapport de force avec lui
alors je crois que l'europe n'est pas en
situation de le faire il faut se mettre
d'accord à 27 elle n'y arrivera pas
comme d'habitude et canto au laboratoire
en 3 intégrations européennes et
souveraineté nationale je pense que
c'est exactement ce qu'on a essayé de
faire ces 30 dernières années en étant à
mi-chemin d'un système fédéral
l'un système des souverainetés ce qui
donne quelque chose d'extrêmement
technocratique où on ne sait pas très
bien qui gouverne je pense que justement
ce système a montré sa très grande
inefficacité
ces dernières années je crois plutôt
mois un système de coopération entre les
souverainetés mettre d'accord plusieurs
souveraineté entre elles ça me paraît
possible un système à 27 mélenchon
intégration les confédérations ça me
paraît être un système bancal d'autant
plus que qui prendrait le le leadership
de cette europe puissance là aujourd'hui
ce sera l'allemagne mais l'allemagne est
une puissance purement économique et qui
a bien du mal à assumer son son son
destin de deux puissances mondiales
capable de s'occuper des grandes
affaires diplomatiques je pense que
c'est lié à son histoire
traumatisé par là la seconde guerre
mondiale et que justement on a essayé de
de construire l'europe sur ce modèle-là
que l'europe sera finalement le
continent de la sortie de l'histoire de
la fin des conflits des rapports de
force et on voit où ça nous mène ça nous
mène à une grande situation de faiblesse
face à ce constat et peut-être cette
réaction d'un internaute qui dit
l'europe pourrait jouer un rôle mais
pour ça il faudrait qu'elle le veuille
malheureusement alors on verra puisque
normalement c'est le 24 septembre que se
déroulera la réunion qui va examiner la
question des sanctions éventuelles
contre la turquie
si on revient à la turquie ce qui est ce
qu'il faut rappeler c'est quand même
qu'on a à faire une évolution qui est
très préoccupante donc reach et erdogan
a transformé ce pays qui avait quand
même fait une vraie évolution vers la
démocratie avec une régression dans un
système qui est un système de
démocrature aligner largement sur celui
de poutine c'est à dire un pouvoir
quasiment à vie des oligarques autour la
suppression de l'état de droit
des centaines de milliers de
fonctionnaires révoquer des soldats des
des officiers des journalistes des
enseignants en prison par par milliers
et donc derrière ni un projet qui est un
projet de reconstitution de l' empire
ottoman avec un fond une base islamique
sunnite bon derrière ça on est d'accord
sur le sur le sol sur le contexte la
question c'est la réponse on a vu après
des mois de 7,2 cette formule mais on a
vu qu' il ya un pays membre de l'union
européenne un pays demande de l'otan qui
était en difficulté
on a vu qu'il y avait des divisions au
sein de l'union européenne il ya qu un
pays qui a volé au secours on peut dire
littéralement c'est la vente de
de ce pays en difficulté de ce pays
européens en difficulté ça a été la
france qui a pu faire la seule réponse
agile rapide et elle a très bien fait
mais ça veut pas dire que c'est pas
forcément la seule réponse efficace
pourquoi parce que la vraie réponse
efficace face à erdogan
ce sont des sanctions économiques et
financières compte tenu de la fragilité
aujourd'hui de l'économie turque est
donc ça c'est pas la france seule qui
peut prendre des sanctions contre la
turquie
ça n'aurait pas grand sens bruit et pas
beaucoup d'efficacité
donc qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire
aujourd'hui premièrement il faut aider
là il faut aider la grèce aider la grèce
la france peut le faire elle l'a montré
avec les manoeuvres maritimes communes
elle a montré avec le la vente des
rafale mais l'europe peut aussi l'aider
puisqu'on a un vrai problème d'atteinte
à la souveraineté d'un pays de l'union
où si l'appel d'un pays de l'otan et
l'europe à l'aide de la grèce notamment
sur le par ailleurs le problème des le
problème des migrants sur lequel on a
une aide très très concrètes notamment
une aide financière
la deuxième chose c'est qu'effectivement
l'europe doit prendre des sanctions
contre art hogan sauf à ce qu'il change
de
de politique et puis enfin la france
seule ne peut pas contrôler la
méditerranée et maintenant il faut quand
même être très clair la méditerranée
c'est la frontière sud du continent
c'est une frontière qui est décisive
ça doit devenir la qu'européen c'est à
dire que on doit se mettre en position
avec des bateaux des satellites des
moyens d'intervention de savoir ce qui
se passe en permanence dans cet espace
est d'être capable d'intervenir pour
gérer les projets gérer les crises il
faut être clair la france seule la
france peut faire des choses mais la
france seule ne peut pas faire ça c'est
là que l'europe est intéressante
alors la meilleure à bande large au
niveau européen reste chaussée dans ses
pantoufles estime à la et la france n'a
pas à s'occuper de la turquie nous
direz-vous sur youtube fier parce que la
turquie est une menace directe ça a été
très bien me dis alors dogan poursuit un
rêve impérial il c'est un rêve
islamistes il explique que les migrants
turcs pour les immigrés turcs ne doivent
pas s'assimiler en europe donc il ya il
ya un an je dirais et puis surtout il
viole la souveraineté grecque et on peut
imaginer que si violent la souveraineté
d'un pays européen
peut-être qu'il il violera s'il en a
l'occasion
la sécurité dans notre pays de cause de
la cause du différend sur les eaux
territoriales s'appelle munich 6
on va tout droit vers une forme de
munich face à face à l'islamisme
conquérant si on raisonne comme ça donc
je crois que emmanuel macron est dans
son rôle et il doit il doit se faire
entendre mais après l'europe puissance
moi je veux bien
on voit bien que l'europe est elle même
sous la coupe de l'otan et que la
turquie et dans l'otan tout ça c'est
beaucoup de contradictions je sais
pourquoi je crois plutôt mois en
l'agilité c'est bien que le peuple la
france ait pris l'initiative elle sera
peut-être suivi par d'autres pays
européens qui ouvriront les yeux quant à
l'aide de l'europe aux migrants moi j'ai
plutôt l'impression que le message de
l'europe sur la question des migrants on
a vu avec angela merkel qui a ouvert les
bas aux migrants de manière totalement
unilatérale sans consulter ses
partenaires bon ou plutôt les cartes
il faudra et aider justement plutôt là
la grèce à sécuriser sa frontière plutôt
que lui donner des aides pour accueillir
les migrants d'autant que la réduction
de la sécurisation de la frontière c'est
exactement ce que fait l'europe
aujourd'hui alors il ya eu un changement
de politique mais c'est très clair que
notamment quant au maire de gan a essayé
d'envoyer des dizaines de milliers de
migrants la dernière fois en grèce du
nord la frontière a été fermée elle a
été fermé y compris avec des
financements européens
donc point à venir quel est le problème
alors ça et les 6 milliards c'est ce
qu'on a versé à erdogan pour empêcher il
demande de la maison pour qu'il pour qui
ben oui mais vous voyez que merkel m
c'est parfaitement exact c'est après
c'est la responsabilité de madame merkel
qui a commis deux énormes erreurs en
2015 et puis ensuite avec cet accord
avec un air de gan
mais vous voyez qu aujourd'hui
l'allemagne a changé de politique et de
ton de même qu'elle change de politique
et ton avec la russie autour de la
sphère navalni donc les choses évoluent
c'est tout à fait vrai qu'il y avait
beaucoup de dysfonctionnements et de
lacunes donc sur la politique monétaire
on a commencé à voir quelque chose qui
allait un peu mieux avec la crise de
2008 sur la partie économique
on a fait un plan de relance qui
améliore les choses avec l'épidémie de
comines le problème qui se pose c'est
est ce qu'il va falloir attendre d'avray
de voir une vraie crise
peut-être avec la turquie pour que les
choses bougent enfin sur le plan de la
sécurité et la turquie qu'on raisonne en
termes d'intérêt européen ou d'intérêt
national
elle pose un vrai problème parce qu'il
ya l'atteinte à la souveraineté de la
grèce parce qu'il ya la présence en
syrie et en libye donc à fond avec les
deux grands pays par lesquels on peut
gérer les flux de migrants et par
ailleurs c'est à proximité immédiate et
enfin sur le gaz en méditerranée
si on arrivait à exploiter correctement
ses il faut voir que c'est le substitut
idéal pour nous au gaz russe
donc c'est une manière de réduire la
dépendance envers la turquie dont
l'essentiel de l'énergie repose enfin
des ressources énergétiques de
l'utilisation de l'énergie repose sur
sur le gaz
oui mais si vous voulez c'est là où air
de guerre un mot mais est-ce que y'a
rien qui empêche de d'ouvrir une
négociation raisonnable entre pays
civilisé sur l'exploitation du gaz de
militaires année ce qui est inadmissible
c'est le sait le coup de force et le
viol de la souveraineté d'un pays la
grèce qui est un pays européens et qui
est censé être l'alliée de la turquie à
la russie parce qu'on a une différence
je pense de vision fondamentale
là dessus moi je pense que justement
pour créer une europe puissance faut une
europe des souverainetés et faut une
europe qui arrime qui qu'il soit capable
justement de négocier d'avoir une
conversation apaisée et respectueuse
avec la turquie
je pense que justement on montre les
muscles face à la turquie qui pourrait
être notre allié pour contenir
erdogan d'une certaine manière et demain
contenir la chine qui sera également un
adversaire important face à l'europe et
à l'occident c'est la question alors
apparemment quand même les internautes
qui s'expriment sur twitter sont
d'accord avec vous un nicolas l'europe
peut jouer un rôle contre la menace
turque contre la glace en tout cas ils
le disent oui à 63%
mais il ya d'autres solutions par
exemple il ya la solution effectivement
comme viens de dire alexandre de faire
de s'appuyer sur la russie de retourner
la russie dans ce dossier ou bien il y
avait la solution sarkozy qu est l union
pour la méditerranée oui enfin mais
l'union pour la méditerranée elle est
mort ni donc ça cesse de toute façon on
voit pas large en attendant on pas trop
non compte tenu de nom mais là il faut
être clair à ce que ce qui était dit sur
le canton à un pays qui fait peser des
menaces pareil direct si on n'a pas une
réponse ferme
ça ne peut pas marcher donc là où il
faut pas être manichéen c'est que qu'est
ce qu'on a comme moyens de riposte
fallait normalement par rapport à la
turquie donc il ya du bilatéral l'aide
directe à la grèce ensuite il ya
l'europe est théoriquement il ya l'otan
l'otan vous l'avez parfaitement rappelé
aujourd'hui elle est complètement
paralysée par l'élection américaine est
par ailleurs par les positions de trump
qui est à la fois hostile à l'otan est
incroyablement proche des airs de gamme
puisque ces chefs d'état avec lequel il
a le plus d'occasions de parler au
téléphone donc une fois qu'il ya plus de
temps les choses sont claires il reste
le bilatéral et l'europe donc agissons
sur les deux plans le plan national a
été bien bien utiliser le plan européen
doit cela des six mois si l'europe est
capable de se mettre d'accord de mettre
des sanctions de spéculer sur la monnaie
turc par exemple avec la bce
gesca favorable j'indique qu'il ya eu
l'agilité le bilatéral me paraît
primordial de s'écouler la livre turque
il suffit de laisser hier de gan faire
ils y arrivent très bien tout seul alors
il ya une autre suggestion c'est celle
qui est donnée par pierre et ça sera
votre dernière élection je voudrais
avoir rapidement ce qu'on a dépassé le
temps si on menaçait de relocaliser les
usines renault qui se trouve
actuellement en turquie erdogan ne
viendrait plus raisonnable ça je crois
que si vous voulez sur les
investissements français de toute
manière vont connaître des jours sans
doute difficile et je pense pas que ce
soit très efficace il faut être clair
danser dans ces régimes dictatoriaux ce
qui fait le plus de mal c'est les
sanctions contre les personnes c'est ce
qu'ont très bien montré les états unis
pour le coup les états unis trompe donc
aujourd'hui il faut des sanctions qui
visent air de gan ses proches et les
oligarques qui sont produits moi je suis
tout à fait pour l'aja re localisation
des usines réseau par renault pas
seulement pour embêter arbaud galles
mais parce que c'est c'est bien de
relocaliser la production
les fondamentaux sont sont assurées donc
dans ce débat entre nicolas baverez et
alexandre ii vecchio erdogan exige une
pique nous dit pierre avec leur
politique nationaliste impérialiste et
expansionniste sont des dangers pour
l'humanité alors je sais pas si vous
avez raison c'est d'ailleurs dans tous
les cas c'est à peu près la thèse que
défend dur en terme peut-être moins
formé par nicolas habas braz donc dans
la chronique à retrouver sur le site sur
le site du figaro l'archipel isation du
monde la france devrait donner le choix
aux etats-unis nous dit nathan soit la
france sur la turquie mais pas les deux
dans l'otan et alors il y avait un débat
par plateforme interposés entre revo qui
je pense fait partie de la team erdogan
la france a suffisamment usées
d'impérialisme pour effectuer divers
colonisation ça suffit au lieu de vous
occuper de sa intéressez-vous à la
persécution des ouigours en chine et en
face on à alain
donc j'ai cité mais pierre également qui
dit le régime turc et nostalgiques de
l'empiré ottoman c'est ce que vous
disiez nicolas et erdogan aux accusé la
france d'être impérialiste la question
quand vous posez sur twitter donc c'est
croyez vous que l'europe peut jouer un
rôle contre les menaces turque contre la
grèce et vous dites oui à 63% le dossier
sur les menaces turc vous pouvez le
retrouver en intégralité sur le site du
figaro vous pouvez également retrouver
le sujet facture notifié qui fait le
point et qui récapitule donc le
différend qu'il ya entre la france et la
turquie
non seulement avec la sphère grecque
mais également les affaires libyennes et
à lire aussi bien sur la dernière
chronique donc de nicolas baverez darche
et archipels isation du monde c'est la
dernière chronique donc de nicolas
baverez et également sont ces deux
livres l'alertent démocratique et le
monde selon tocqueville recomposition le
nouveau monde populiste et le dernier
livre d'alexandre ii vecchio et c'est
aux éditions du cerf
qu'est-ce qu'on se retrouve sur le
figaro évoque sur figaro box un article
de barbara lefebvre l'a dernièrement
également oui oui sans doute
prochainement sur le le séparatisme et
l'amalgamé qui est fait entre le
justement le danger islamiste dans
certains quartiers et le séparatisme des
riches ou le séparatisme des écoles
privées catholiques ça me parait tu as
un amalgame est une manière de
s'aveugler sur la réalité médecins au
sujet de débat on y reviendra dans les
prochains jours sans doute peut-être en
tout cas je vous donne rendez vous
demain ici même heure même endroit pour
une autre émission de notre édition de
point de vue
[Musique]